(upbeat music)
Hi, Michelle.
Hi
How's it going?
I'm so excited.
We're gonna get you dressed so it will be super fun
and you're going to the park.
Yeah.
Yes.
We've got some beautiful colors, let me know-
Love that color.
Yeah.
And then you said you liked green so.
I do like green, it's my favorite.
This is really beautiful.
And
(upbeat music)
Hi, oh.
Hi.
See, this color is beautiful on you.
Ah.
This one feels a lot better.
How do you feel?
Not gonna lie, I like it better than I thought I would.
I don't know but I feel it.
That is beautiful.
This color is so gorgeous on you.
I love it.
(upbeat music)
That's exciting.
It is.
(upbeat music)
You look gorgeous.
Thank you so much.
You're welcome.
Hi Michelle.
Hi.
You look beautiful.
Yeah, I feel beautiful.
I wanna make sure that you're really feeling confident
about your flirting skills and your communication style
because a lot of times if you've been in a relationship
for a long time and you haven't been dating those skills
kind of, they wane.
You need to practice them.
Got it.
When you're on the date I want you to think of every time
he says something think in your mind, "Yes, and".
Yes meaning you hear him, you acknowledge what he's saying
and you add on with something from your personal experience.
The other thing that is very bonding for two people
on a date is mirroring.
You can actually create the feeling of connection,
seeing what he's doing with his body language or his tone
of voice and mirroring that yourself.
So remember those tips.
I think it's gonna go great.
I'm really excited for you.
(audience clapping)
Oh, Damona I love you and Michelle I'm so excited.
When we come back we're gonna find out what happened
on Michelle's date 'cause our cameras followed along
plus yeah, it's welcome to my world and she's here
to give us all the details.
(upbeat music)